time now for the uplift at eight we
share stories that we're bringing some
joy to your day i could use some vlad
give me a big old cup of juice all right
i always say this is the best thing
you're gonna hear all day so today's
uplift is about the ultimate surprise
for two first-time grandparents so they
knew their daughter-in-law was pregnant
but they had no idea that she'd gone
into labor until this moment take a look
thank you
what
what
you just are you kidding me did you know
this
oh my god
oh my god little man
[Music]
i also like how grandpa was like you
the guy who's chewing is amazing he's so
good that's baby axe and meeting his
grandparents for the first time back in
october so as soon as new parents sienna
and braden left the hospital they took
him straight to his grandma and
grandpa's house to surprise them they
recently posted this video on tick tock
and it
it's gotten more than 15 million views
we spoke with them about pulling off
that surprise introduction
i'm horrible at keeping secrets so i
just kind of wanted it to get out of the
way like we're both really excited to
show him and we hadn't posted any
pictures or anything and obviously
spending like a full 24 hours we're just
really excited to show them all
so they told us that axon is a very very
very happy baby and everyone in the
family loves to spoil him but of course
they do look at that face oh so look at
that smile i know grandparents across
the country are outraged right now i
know
like in the kitchen two minutes after
the video rolled they were like so did
you not want us to cut like i had a
background guilt is going to start
exactly